CNN's own employees are disparaging the
Trump town hall employees inside the
company are slamming the network for
giving Trump a platform to spout false
claims on a multitude of issues we have
this uh thread from Brian stelter I love
this one because it shows how out of
touch they are Chris Licht begins CNN's
9am editorial call praising Caitlin
Collins for a quote masterful
performance last night he says I
couldn't be more proud of her and the
whole team in New Hampshire then he says
he's aware of the backlash more to come
okay
CNN's doomed if if they thought Caitlin
Collins did a good job that they're just
done it was it was a poor performance by
an individual who should not be in that
position Caitlyn Collins does not have
the Persona the presence the gravitas
the talent capability to stand up
against a Donald Trump figure in this
way she just comes off as whiny the
whole time constantly interrupting him
no fun she was literally the no fun
person but but that's like all the Press
can do at this point right like they all
know that they're not allowed to be
objective anymore they all know that
they're not allowed to let him get up
there and give a fair hearing they all
understand that it's their job to
destroy this person publicly and if they
don't do that they're going to get
criticized for being too light on Trump
for facilitating him for you know and
putting him up there and so they
understand that they have to just Badger
him like this and it doesn't matter how
ridiculous they look because they don't
care about the audience and they don't
care about the ratings they care about
the approval of their friends they care
about the approval of the crowd they
care about their standing in the
Progressive Movement that's all that
matters they're not Journal homeless in
any kind of significant way that you
think about they are very clearly
Democratic apparatchics and that's the
only measure of success they have this
is this is really good news really
really good news they are eating
themselves from the inside they can't
this was 3.3 million viewers CNN needs
this kind of traffic they need to go on
TV and have a real conversation about
what Americans actually want they can't
because the cult is holding them down by
their ankles this just means seeing and
I hope you're listening CNN or if you
work there your company is crumbling
because you are a zombie cult and I
don't care in fact I'm ready to crack
open that Louis XII and share a little
bottle of fine cognac to celebrate the
demise of CNN I can't wait for it
we'll mix it with Diet Coke yeah maybe
MTV News just died BuzzFeed news is over
vices nearing bankruptcy it's amazing
well Soros I guess is bailing out Vice
and now CNN can't even do any it's like
I just want to say how funny it is that
CNN is desperate saying please help us
watch our Channel and they finally got
something Trump and they're like this
might save us and the left comes with
pitchforks crowbars and baseball
struggle sessions
and it's like Oren said every single
move that they make is calculated to
boost their own personal social credit
score every single one of these people
all that matters is that those around
them say you were a good Progressive you
behaved well you did what you were
supposed to do you pushed back properly
none of it's about trying to find Common
Ground none of it's about trying to get
more information for Their audience
about the 2020 election about the Russia
Ukraine conflict about any other
relevant issue it's about showing them
that I'm good because I don't like Trump
we are we are closer to nuclear war than
we have been since the 60s it is an
actual possibility that I mean no one
would be completely and utterly shocked
if Putin launched a couple nuclear uh
artillery strikes well in Ukraine would
become it wouldn't be like oh my God
that came out of nowhere no they're at
War and they've got there's a lot of
people dying and that is something that
could actually happen I want to tell you
what I see when I watch a CNN thing it
feels like I went to a skate park and
they didn't say anything about that it
feels like I'm at a skate park and
there's a bunch of little kids on
scooters riding around and you're like
these kids don't know etiquette they're
going the wrong way and it's very
dangerous because if you're if you're
going faster and do a big old kickflip
you crash into one of these kids you get
hurt the kid gets hurts like oh that's
what I see when I watch CNN Caitlyn
Collins a really really good example of
this it's obvious she has no idea what
she's talking about
she has no views of her own to actually
insert to to debate Trump with so
instead she's just debating him in a
generic
and my favorite example is when Trump
said that he offered the National Guard
to DC but it was rejected she goes
that's not true your own Chris Chris
Miller that didn't happen
it is literally true she was
interrupting Trump and she was wrong
factually wrong that's the worst thing
so you have someone if Caitlyn comes as
a pundit of someone who who opines on
issues and no and has an in-depth view
on these things and wanted to push back
on Trump I'd be like that's interesting
it's a debate but she's supposed to be a
moderator and what a moderator does says
Trump here's a question what do you
think interesting how do you respond to
this question if if Trump said look you
know I was I was offering up National
Guard and they didn't want it they said
no then she said well Chris Miller wrote
in his book that you did not authorize
the deployment then you'd say I did
offer it to DC and they said no so there
is a difference in the moderation
moderator moderator should then say
it's all about boosting that social
credit score you made a very good point
about the fact that there is very high
risk of nuclear war any risk is too much
risk in some sense but instead of
focusing on that and and changing the
conversation any questions about it but
instead of engaging that question with
any level of social responsibility she
wanted Trump to be as inflammatory and
bombastic as possible and instead of
focusing on the possibility of nuclear
war
the left instead wants to prioritize the
fact that you drove your car too many
miles last week and that's making the
weather angry right like their
apocalyptic fears are of things that
everyday Americans do in order to live
their lives and they involve basically
no focus on powerful people who are
profiting millions even billions of
dollars off of these conflicts overseas
that we don't need to be involved with
which could legitimately result in
millions and millions and millions of
deaths I I I do want to give a shout out
to our friend Sunny Hosten over at the
view for trashing Caitlyn Collins over
the Trump Town Hall Fiasco masterful job
wow I agree with her wow she was
surprised Kalyn Collins exemplified what
it means to be a world-class journalist
she asked tough fair questions CNN
sending a statement at the Town Hall and
she followed up with the fact followed
up in fact checked Trump in real time to
arm voters with crucial information
that's what CNN is is betting on
activism
to be honest I didn't like the platform
but I also want to say this because I
know she's getting Flack from from some
folk scale counted a masterful job
Griffin noted masterful job wow
as a young woman seeing a 30 year old
journalist take it to one of the most
powerful men in the world Griffin
continued as hosted out snide asides she
got in there it's really easy Austin
then proceeded to uh to Monday Morning
Quarterback it well we get it I think I
think she did a terrible job and if CNN
is betting on that I'm just really
excited that's like at least Don Lemon
had
some fire in him you know what I mean
like Don Lemon was a crazy man but he
would argue with Vivek and you'd be like
I can't believe he's actually like but
you knew it was coming you knew he was
Kailyn Collins it's like putting a a
mannequin on stage and then like pulling
the rip cord and she's like no Trump you
are wrong well the one difference is she
never asked him whatever your ethnicity
is well she was scolding him yeah that
would have been I mean yeah at this
point they just don't understand how to
handle him he doesn't care he doesn't
give them the respect they believe they
deserve they're so in-depth they've
never run into anyone who doesn't just
automatically genuflect in front of them
because they're the media and they're
the king makers and you're they're the
ones that have to be served at any
moment because they control your image
and that's what Trump does so well he
has the image maybe it's not always a
great one sometimes he goes you know
wild but he's the one in control he's
the one in the driver's seat and it
drives them nuts I mean what are they
gonna do they've called this guy Hitler
they've called this guy Satan are they
going to pretend like he had a good
performance so they could pretend like
their person did a bad job they've got
to lie about it it's the only thing
they've got left and that's why they
keep looking more and more ridiculous
yeah no I wonder how much they pay her
Caitlin Collins we talked about it last
night 77 cents on the dollar for the men
they have working there Tim and it's a
problem and it's a problem well actually
let me let me let me let me do something
you know she made significantly less
money than the man she was on stage with
last night significantly lower net worth
overall
let's do it explain that to me
Don lemon's salary because I don't
understand why the world check it out
the New York Times in April said Don
lemon's salary was seven million all
right let's do uh Caitlyn Collins salary
here and uh Google says one to three
million
so it's it's worse than 77 cents on the
dollar Sheamus I think that Don Lemon
like 40 cents on the dollar and I'm sure
they pull in the exact same numbers for
the network I'd be curious to see how
much viewership Don Lemon pulls in as
opposed to her because this could be a
classic example of workplace sexism and
I think Don needs to acknowledge his
unearned privilege well apparently now
they're going to give her Cuomo's time
slot her it's really sad she's getting a
that's the that's I think that's
confirmed actually oh my that she's
getting the 9 pm CNN time slot and uh
it's just not no like Aaron Burnett I
get like and Anderson Cooper I get
Caitlyn Collins it's like a mannequin on
TV it's just like looking at a chunk of
plastic with a with a mouth
there's nothing there that's how you
view women it's him no just Kayla sounds
like Aaron Burnett actually as like
sexist animal but it's not sexist if
I've compliment another woman
no well no any anytime you say it no no
Tim I don't think you understand like I
had my fingers at the time you criticize
any person from any group that means you
hate the entire group do you understand
oh yeah sorry buddy you're going to
sexist jail
now I think um I was like I talked about
this earlier like Dana Bash like CNN has
female personalities and male
personalities and you get it
Caitlyn Collins I don't understand
they're just like help we need young
people what do we do like this is the
best we could do I don't know throw
spaghetti at the wall and see what
sticks
I I want to figure out her ratings as
opposed to Don lemon's ratings to see if
she's getting ripped off I don't I don't
I'll I will negotiate for it I will go
to that Network and let them know that
she's worth more now Don lemon's not
there anymore maybe they couldn't afford
him giving his ratings I don't know but
I think it's telling that he makes so
much more than her and he's a man I we
made but I actually fair point I think
we do need to uh every every one of us
tweeted CNN and demand they pay Caitlin
Collins exactly what they pay Anderson
Cooper it is not fair it's not fair and
and when she takes if she takes up the 9
pm slot she should get 100 the same
amount that Cuomo got that's how it
works and what was Cuomo's salary do we
know what Cuomo salary was Sheamus I
like your turn is the new glorious
Steinem thank you well look I I someone
has to continue the Legacy it's very
important and what I will say is that
according to two different sources
Anderson Cooper's salary is 12 million
dollars
12 I don't want to live in a country
where everyone isn't making 12 million
dollars a year right like remember when
uh Bloomberg spent 500 million dollars
on the election to get heckled that was
that right bullied that means there's
300 million people in the United States
he could have given every American 1
million dollars remember that lady said
that yeah it's actually a dollar Thirty
not a million dollars I think everyone
gets a dollar oh my God yeah oh no no I
think if CNN doesn't pay Caitlin Collins
12 million dollars it proves they're
sexist that's exactly right then by the
way what is the money somewhere I think
the average share in the national debt
per person is about two hundred thousand
dollars so just to be clear just to be
clear with the sum of money that Tim
just laid out that would give every
person one dollar and thirty cents right
you want to do the math on confiscating
all the wealth from all the billionaires
the way they talk about to fund all
their social programs like we literally
wouldn't even make a dent in the money
that we owe how about we do this if you
want to vote you have to pay more in
taxes than the national debt per person
oh my gosh you have to pay off your
share of the national debt so if it's
200 000 per person and rising and it's
out of your control you would need to
make what is that so uh that so you'd
have to make like 500 000 a year well no
no you just pay off your share of the
debt once
oh yeah good point yeah yeah you just
you pay off your share of the debt once
and now now you get to vote I think I
think that's the only like 10 people
voting thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time